foreign
Colorado and talk to Joe what's up Joe
hey Dr Delaney first time uh caller I'm
glad and honored to talk to you today
and I'm honored that you called man
what's up
so
um my question is and I can explain the
back story am I crazy for thinking that
my wife can use her anxiety disorder as
a weapon against me
as somebody who was once diagnosed with
an anxiety disorder no they make
extraordinary weapons oh like give me
give me your give me your uh your
backstory
okay so I've been married a little over
a year
and um
I didn't know about my wife's um
anxiety disorder the first time we were
together we were together about a year
and a half
we split up and then covet happened and
we got back together a year later we got
engaged a year later we got married and
here we are
um
I didn't know about my wife's anxiety
disorder the first time we went out and
um
before she was with me
um she was with a person who was very
verbally abusive that brought out her
anxiety as from her childhood that got
worse and worse
um
ever since we got engaged into married
it comes out a little more and more the
longer that we're together
um and it it shows in weird ways
um right now my major issue that I have
is
my my wife spends a lot of money on
mobile applications on her phone that
she says helps her anxiety
absolutely bull crap on a stick makes it
10 times worse 100 times worse
so when she was with her ex her common
thing would be to drive around the metro
area that I live in for an hour to two
hours till she was able to calm down and
sleep that was her
anxiety coping mechanism and now it's
it's this
um it's gotten to a really bad point
um so just to give you a parameter it's
been about a thousand dollars in this
calendar year which on games like on
phone games
yes so like if you imagine like um
that's one thousand more dollars than
I've ever spent on a mobile game
and I'll just see
I won't name the developer I don't want
to insult them on your show but I'll
just see like constant work I like items
on here and
I suffer from Financial anxiety uh
having a lack or something like an
overdraft causes me to have a visceral
reaction because I never had that before
I was with my partner I never
overdrafted my checking account
um and I I knew exactly how much money
was in my checking account at all times
so being with my my partner now
she's exactly the opposite and she
spends money
on this on that and it's just um
I I I don't know I I can't get her to
budget I've tried that route
let me let me hop in here let me hop in
here okay so first and foremost cancel
that credit card immediately today
okay okay
um this is going to get out of control
in a wild way and I'd be willing to bet
money maybe wrong I'd be willing to bet
money no no pun intended here
um that this is not the only thing she's
spending money on
yeah there's no possible way this is the
only thing and this is one of those
moments that people find out like it was
a thousand bucks It Was Eighteen hundred
dollars suddenly it's 25
000 bucks and it's you're talking a
couple of years to recover from it I
would cancel that card today
this is you stopping the bleeding of
somebody you love right in front of you
and they may say ouch this hurts I hate
this get your hands off me I'm not gonna
let you bleed out in front of me
okay that's what that move is all right
backing out
listen to me super clear and super
careful okay
all anxiety is is an alarm system for
your body period
it is not a driver of behavior it
doesn't make you do things you don't
want to do
it doesn't force you into other
behaviors XYZ they fill in the blank
I'll even go one step further she chose
to remain in that relationship with that
guy and not to undermine abusive
relationships man I've sat with people
forever in the in those situations
they're brutal and ugly
that guy didn't set didn't make her
anxiety worse
her body was screaming at her to get out
of the situation and she stayed
and it got louder and it got louder and
it got louder
and so I don't want to demonize anxiety
I don't want to live in a house without
a smoke detector that's insane right
what I want to do is begin to ask what
about this life what about this
ecosystem that this body lives in that
this person lives in your wife or your
your friend or whoever or you
what is it about this ecosystem that my
body keeps telling me we're not safe
we're not safe we're not safe we're not
safe
because most people spend all their time
trying to shut the alarm off instead of
dealing with the fire
okay so number two
and any sort of diagnosis is a context
not an excuse
I had was diagnosed at one point with
OCD I had anxiety all those things fine
I still had to show up at work
and I get distracted counting things and
I have to check my locks a bunch okay
great that means I gotta get up 15
minutes earlier
or five minutes earlier or two minutes
earlier
that means I have to be really really
particular about how I exercise how I
reach out to friends and Community how I
take care of my body et cetera and by
the way like I don't make any laps
around my house much anymore
it's gone
so to say like I have to do this because
it's completely opposite in fact it
strengthens it number three here's the
gnarly thing about anxiety
in her case something is setting that
trigger off and I have a feeling I know
what it is and you're not going to like
it but I'll tell you in just a second
it sets that alarm off to which she
immediately runs to a numbing
um a numbing Behavior well that's
driving around for two hours listening
to sad songs listening to Olivia
Rodriguez and singing and singing or it
is her sitting in a bathroom with the
door locked on video games on her phone
whatever it is it's a numbing Behavior
here's the problem her brain won
her brain sounded an alarm for her to
avoid a situation that it is deemed a
threat whether that's loneliness whether
that's a scary romantic partner whether
that's any number of things Financial
stress whatever it is
and when she goes to a numbing Behavior
the body goes ah we avoided it and it
puts a GPS pin in that move this one
works do it louder next time
and so the only way to heal from anxiety
the only way to deal with those alarms
is to run directly towards them
that's it
and I don't mean that in some woo-woo
fluffy way I mean directly at them
like so in your case
why am I so why does my body try to get
my attention every time there's a dollar
missing in my account
the reason I had Financial anxiety if
you will that's not even a diagnostic
but I get stressed out money was so
contentious we didn't have any growing
up it was scary and it also my dad was a
policeman and my community didn't pay
him enough to give us groceries and I
remember resenting that it was all wound
up in that
and so I went and borrowed six figures
worth of student loans and cars and
houses and all this crap so that I could
not be that and I ended up in a bigger
hole than my old man ever was in
and so my body was letting me know
you're not safe You're Not Safe You're
Not Safe You're Not Safe you see what
I'm saying so anxiety is not the bad guy
here this world is
now when you say you have anxiety
anxiousness what often happens when
somebody is their body is responding
anxiously
they partner up with another anxious
person
and that electricity feeds that
electricity which feeds that electricity
and suddenly you get two radioactive
people sharing a bed together and it's
combustible
so are you an anxious guy too or a very
particular guy or a very I don't say OCD
in the clinical sense but a very
everything's got to be an order kind of
guy
I'm very analytical yeah
analytical what a positive spin well
done
um how long does she struggled with this
anxiety
um for about five years which would be
about the time she was with the ACT I
would be willing to bet my car it's not
a nice one that it's been going on way
longer than that
yeah if she traced it back to when she
was a kid
he was adopted she was adopted and she
doesn't
her
birth mom is not
um there in the head
um would probably be the two sheets to
the win would probably be a good way of
describing her mother's mental acuity
she's not yeah she's struggling what
about her anyway we can go down that
road we don't have to do that right now
um
I'll give you the line that snapped me
out of it
here is a direct quote from my wife
this is about 12 years ago now
she said in a very quiet calm manner
I am watching the man I love die
and I can't sit here and watch that
will you please go talk to somebody
and my numbing behaviors Joe were work
my numbing behaviors were
um
uh
uh reading Journal articles
and creating these big Maps oh I could
figure out how people worked
my numbing things were watching stand-up
comedians and like I had notebooks where
I was charting out which jokes were
funny and how long they took between it
was insane
everybody's got different numbing things
but my wife sat down and said I'm
watching you die and I love you too much
and it was that moment that I finally
felt somebody loved me so much that they
weren't interested in what I was in all
this peripheral stuff they were just
watching me drown
and it I burned them every time they
reached into help
so I went and got help
yeah I think that's a lot of it it is
but you trying to solve the Alarm
Systems will not work they will just
reinforce them because her body will
tell her hey he doesn't see the threat
let's ring the sucker even louder he
can't hear these things
and every time you go to the periphery
and say hey you need to stop doing this
she's going to move to another either
her body's gonna accept that as
rejection
which is a Cornerstone of an anxious
body is a lack of connection
um which is weird because you're like
we're married we're right here we sleep
together we sleep in the same bed
but her body is saying not safe not safe
not safe and so the path forward here is
I'm going to provide a safe place for
you
and me
and that safe place starts with me
telling you I love you so much I can't
watch you I can't watch you die I can't
watch you numb your life out you're
worth more than a numbed out life
does that make sense
yeah
is that ringing is any of this ringing
true to your home
yeah I I mean I I hope she never dies
off of mobile apps and her anxiety I
just
it's not that I love her a lot I know
Joe but it's not about the mobile apps
because I promise you I promise you and
you know this
you're married to a taser
yeah
and this is just one of 15 different
numbing things but I'll tell you it
escalates and it moves and it goes from
mobile apps to
um
some guy who really thinks she's cute
and funny at work
who sends one funny emoji that she
responds to with one funny emoji it goes
to
one more drink
it goes to I'm just gonna go to bed
early
just done this for too long
it's not about the mobile apps
it's about watching your wife feel like
she has to hide from her own life
because she can't handle how intense it
is and it feels like I gotta run away
from that intensity and the only way to
heal is to run directly into it most of
us can't do that by ourselves
you gotta call a professional get some
help you gotta go see a counselor and
say I'm tired of being this exhausted
my husband told me he loves me so much
and he's watching me slowly drain out of
my own life and I want to stop that
foreign
you a copy of building a non-anxious
life and I want you all to go through
that book together
I'll give you a road map or at least
give you all some questions to ask
yourself inside your own home
to begin to say okay why are these
alarms ringing all the time in here
and you my friend need to ask those
questions too because I think they're
reading off in your life too you've just
chosen to to try to handle them by being
very analytical
I've tried to handle them by ignoring
them both strategies are pathological to
their extremes
but I want you to read this book
together and start looking at each one
of these pieces and if you get to a
piece you can't dig into that's when you
call a counselor and say I need some
help here
I've got high hopes for your marriage
because mine is is as good as they come
and
I had a partner that stuck with me she
kept calling me out and kept saying I
miss you where are you where are you
and then Allen did the work y'all can
too I promise